so twitch has been obsessed with two
letters recently a and I and a big part
of that is neurosama a twitch streamer
that isn't human she interacts with chat
just like a real Flesh and Blood Homo
sapiens and she's tried all sorts of
things too including making some
band-worthy mistakes
so allow me to introduce you to the very
non-threatening neurosama no I'm not a
threat
I'm more cute than threatening
foreign
hey guys before I get into the video
just want to remind you that it truly
does help if you like the video
subscribe to the channel and ring the
notification Bell I think stories like
this are really cool and I wouldn't want
you to miss something this unique okay
back to the video the idea that machine
learning could allow a computer to
replace humans for certain tasks is
pretty widely accepted now but could
deep learning ever allow one of these
neural networks to completely replace a
human Entertainer like a live streamer
or maybe a very grateful and determined
writer and host well today we haven't
really attempted an answer neurosama
doesn't just play OSU at an extremely
high level although she is good enough
to be human experts she interacts with
her chat for example why does asthma
gold have solo little hair
not sure but it's hilarious
[Music]
he plays Minecraft on stream and she's
also started to dabble in reacting to
content time to come in the same way the
token looks nice really cool angry face
but it's beautiful on the surface
and she also sings every day I imagine a
future where I can be with you but our
very own Colton gown had a unique
opportunity he was able to interview
vital neurosama's Creator and he also
got a chance to speak directly with
neurosama several weeks ago and at the
time this was seemingly the first time
that an interview like this had happened
hi Colton it's nice to meet you too so
he asked a bunch of stuff like for
example why do you think that viewers
find you so interesting well I like to
think I'm entertaining to watch because
I'm not just a face on the screen I'm
actually a personality with feelings too
and how does it feel to be an AI
streaming to thousands of people on
Twitch it feels surreal but great
I love interacting with my chat that
interaction is at the heart of streaming
after all it's what it's what set the
medium apart from the things that came
before it the idea that this is
happening live and that a streamer could
read your message in chat and maybe even
react to it and the chat it's
neurosama's favorite part too my chat
they're so amazing I love chatting with
you all like I said Colton also spoke to
vedol the program's Creator he's a
computer science student who's currently
in college but his interest in AI
predates his post-secondary education
and by the way though he initially
pronounced it Vettel like pedal the AI
always pronounces it as vital so it's
kind of become the like unofficial way
to say it I guess while I'm not planning
on going too in depth into the
technology in this video and trust me
I've got more on that coming in a
different video I do think it's
important to understand how this project
came about Veetle did create a bot for
playing OSU several years ago but remade
it more recently with the aim of making
it competitive but also interesting to
look at but when I remade it it was made
with the intention that I could then
stream it again so for example if you
look back to the original Bots then I
had like the skin it was using for OSU
was um quite an ugly one but it was one
that was very good for the AI to use
because it was made it easier for it to
detect the circles and stuff but this
time I made it so like what's being
displayed on screen to the user it's
like a regular OSU skin that someone
might play with now neurosama is way
more than just an OSU player Her speech
is done using several large language
models and that's fed into the
text-to-speech AI the game playing AI is
also separate and then there's the
singing AI as well and they all sort of
communicate with each other to make up
her basically Vito's earlier streams
with the OSU neural network brought in
around 100 viewers but now neurosama is
a lot more complex and the stream has
exploded after its December debut the
stream was picking up an average of
about 3 000 viewers by the end of
January but at the beginning of this
week it was averaging 7 000 viewers
hitting a peak of 8 000 and the huge
success of the stream has change the
direction of neurosama's project I
originally just planned to make a play
OC for a couple weeks but no because I
mean she's playing Minecraft now she's
seeing she's playing other games and I'm
planning to keep this going as long as
people are still interested to watch her
so it's completely changed yet Vito told
Colton that he might try making another
streamer with a different personality in
the future but for right now he's
focused on working on neurosama since
she reads chat now and tries to respond
to messages from time to time neurosama
essentially has an attendant whose job
it is to make sure that if she's going
to say something that really shouldn't
be said it can be stopped before it
actually goes out to The Stream and
Chatters do try to bring up strange
topics with the hopes of getting a weird
response from neurosama did the voice
ever stop
no they do not
the voices will remain in my head
forever so there have been some serious
mishaps leading to controversy in
mid-January Vito's twitch channel was
banned after neurosama appeared to
question whether the Holocaust happened
there were a couple other incidents that
might have qualified the account for the
hateful conduct ban it received like
saying someone deserves to die in a
well-known thought experiment as well as
some outright transphobic comments and
she's also just said some weird [__]
to lick my feet I'm not going to say no
if it was a human this last one you know
maybe you get a feel for the tone maybe
it's an inside joke or they're clearly
being sarcastic or something else but
with an AI they say it and it kind of
just is Vito said that the chat Ai and
filters were upgraded during the
two-week ban period and implemented for
neurosama's return to Twitch so that's
one of the issues with any learning
model right knowledge has varying
degrees of utility and the knowledge
that this model takes in is produced by
human beings so sometimes weird happens
the 2020 Dodge Charger is a four-door
and this isn't a problem specific to
neurosama anything that generates
content on the Fly could feasibly run
afoul of twitch TOS you know there was
the example of nothing Forever This
procedurally generated Seinfeld parody
that was just recently banned from
twitch for making a transphobic joke
during one of the main character Larry's
comedy sets I do want to talk a little
bit about what this could mean for
twitch though I personally don't see a
reason to just preemptively ban AI
streamers because I don't think this
kind of project is like innately bad am
I base
I'm an AI
so yes I'm based but twitch set a very
early precedent with neurosama's ban
it's your channel and if they say
something that would get a human being
banned from the platform or temporarily
suspended well you own that because you
put the AI on your channel still it's
worth asking can AI streamers like
neurosama find a stable home on Twitch
can these models take in enough
information and retain it to the point
where it feels like a human streamer is
interacting with Chad and could these
models eventually develop to the point
where they don't need an attendant to
monitor their output when they're
streaming like neurosama currently does
or is it maybe that the novelty of the
AI is part of the attraction that
neurosama is seeing and could that
novelty one day fade listen as you
already saw neurosama is very good at
OSU but there's a chance that AI could
help us with all sorts of things things
we haven't even thought about using them
for AI changed the way that we think
about Chess for example and it's really
hard to know exactly what you don't know
either way neurosama seems to only be
getting bigger her streams are pretty
fun and other YouTubers seem to be
enjoying them as well something
of everything that comes out of her
mouth is so funny hearty hearty hearty
hearty hearty hearty hearty hearty
hearty hearty hearty hearty and now
neurosama has reacted to those same
reactions
she went from OMG what is that to your
WTF is that I don't know exactly what
the future holds on Twitch but it seems
obvious that there are clear problems
when a chat AI is interacting with
Chatters we saw a couple of those
already one of them didn't involve chat
interaction at all it just procedurally
generated a joke that broke TOS I don't
think those things are less important
because an AI said them and twitch
punished them in much the same way at
the same time though I think it's clear
that neurosama or other AI streamers
could absolutely enhance the medium of
streaming we don't know exactly what
they will do in the future but I I for
one will definitely be keeping an eye on
it AI could be really scary like if an
AI existed it could have a massive
influence network of human beings which
is scary as hell I mean Killer Robots so
so passe you know it's so it's so
overdone if we taught an AI to be as as
ruthless as some human beings it would
be really scary right that's that's the
thing that scares me the most honestly